parmi les condamnés qui espère être
innocenté le plus lourdement frappée ce
prêtre ouvrier sept ans de prison quatre
seulement avaient été requis par le
parquet aurélia guima vincent ferreira
ils ont repris leur action dès les
premières heures de la journée au
lendemain d'un verdict qui ne
comprennent pas les membres du comité de
soutien de l'abbé viel appel par
dizaines tous qu'il faut continuer il
faut se réorganiser il faut on peut pas
laisser faire ça j'ai sans arrêter
l'école la remobilisation après le choc
d'hier soir une rare celui qu'ils
soutiennent depuis la première heure le
prêtre ouvrier de l' affaire d'outreau a
été reconnu coupable de trois viols et
deux agressions sexuelles pour lui cette
emprise
la formation se révolter déception
cruelle
après l'espoir du 27 mai dernier
disculpé par sa principale accusatrice
dominique viel avaient été libérés mais
les jurés eux n'ont pas cru à
l'innocence du voisin le plus proche du
couple badaoui delay celui aussi que
certains enfants n'ont cessé d'accuser
il fallait aller jusqu'au bout à partir
du moment où l'on considérait que la
parole des enfants n'étaient plus fiable
pour certains il ne restait plus rien
pas plus pour dominique viel que pour
les autres
dominique viel réincarcéré très tôt ce
matin la prison de longuenesse a d'ores
et déjà décidé de faire appel